Rogan did Grill him a bit when it came
to pushing vaccines and General Health
and diet and vitamins and everything
else because Rogan was to his credit
always somewhat skeptical about all of
this stuff do you take care of your
immune system in other ways do you take
probiotics are you cautious about your
diet
um I'm not as cautious about my diet as
I should be I'm a junk foodaholic
actually well that seems like a terrible
thing for your health it is a terrible
thing for my health and something my
wife is working on but that seems
ridiculous for someone who works with
health yeah yeah
sometimes man I just don't get it right
how often what how often how often do I
steal a bag of chips or something like
that garbage uh uh I don't know no no
hopefully not every day but you know
hopefully not every day maybe a couple
of times a week oh that's what with
Rachel my uh my daughter with autism
that's like our thing is to go to the
it's called The Burger Joint or to Shake
Shack to get a to get a cheeseburger
we'll stick sneak some fries so
um so you live in large we call it like
that mouth pleasure so much you're
willing to sacrifice a little bit I am
yeah you know I you know I I can I have
to concede that's the case well there's
I mean I don't have to tell you but
there's a large body of data that
connects poor diet to a host of diseases
that seems like a crazy decision for a
guy in your line of work there you go
sometimes the uh
sometimes the it's not all brain it's uh
it's something else but I mean if you
ate healthy food I mean the thing is
your body starts craving healthy food
you start feeling yeah no no questions
no question about it do you take
vitamins I don't take vitamins really
yeah wow I think they do I don't think
they're neither because most and the
Americans and the American up hold up
hold up you don't think they're needed
while you're eating junk food well
hopefully I'm not only eating junk food
but you know there's a large body of
clinical research on the efficacy of
vitamins especially vitamins D vitamins
I have taken vitamin D for periods and
the recommendation of my internist and
what about essential fatty acids which
are great for your brain fish oil all
these different things that are
fantastic I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
argue with you
you got it you got you got it over me
yeah you gotta listen but it would you
would have a much better argument you're
making my wife stay here if you're
taking care of yourself hundred percent
instead of but you still need but you
still need your vaccines I'm sure you do
but vaccines aren't going to prevent
cancer no that's true right that's true
there's a lot of diseases or diabetes or
cardiovascular disease right A lot of
these diseases are connected directly to
diet right yeah yeah come on and the
other lifestyle should change yeah
you run yeah do you not very well but no
but you do okay yeah we're gonna get you
healthy buddy yeah can't be pushing only
chemicals in injectable forms to
facilitate health fair enough yeah right
not chemicals they're vaccines oh I'm
sorry what's in them what it's not I
mean it's some sort of chemical no no
other antigens right they're they're
fluid macromolecules what's the liquids
uh typically it would be saline or you
know salt water okay so I thought that
was just like an interesting moment to
frame some of this like there you have a
Doctor Who's whatever he's a little
overweight okay so be it but he's
basically telling you he's addicted to
junk food and he doesn't take vit
vitamins but here he is on these shows
and believe me he was all over MSNBC and
CNN and all The Usual Suspects for three
years basically pushing vaccines on
people and remember remember all that
time during covid why we kept asking why
why are they not having more
nutritionists on why are they not having
more fitness experts on